Dominique Verrien bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes sénatrice Union
centriste de l'Yonne on va revenir sur
cette actualité sociale cette actualité
politique avec cette onzième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites des rassemblements partout
dans toute la France des mobilisations
encore très fortes est-ce que il faut
parler des soufflement
visiblement effectivement il y a moins
de manifestants
de toute façon sincèrement aucune
réforme des retraites n'est passée en
douceur moi je me souviens au moment où
je commençais à travailler je venais de
créer une entreprise quand il y a eu des
grèves de 95 et je trouve qu'on n'y fait
pas assez référence c'était aussi très
très fort en fait dès qu'on veut toucher
aux retraites c'est forcément très
compliqué
et en 95 la réforme avait été retirée
oui effectivement et mais je note aussi
qu'en 95 après le président avait décidé
de dissoudre et on avait eu ensuite une
cohabitation donc on peut comprendre
pourquoi le président aujourd'hui hésite
à refaire les erreurs de 95 quoi aux
manifestants stop arrêtez vous avez
perdu la bataille
non j'avoue que si je devais dire
quelque chose ce serait beaucoup plus au
gouvernement mais c'est peut-être un
petit peu tard c'est à dire que c'était
bien en amont personne jusqu'à présent
n'a osé faire une réforme des retraites
sans s'associer à la CGT seul ce
gouvernement a pensé qu'il était plus
fort et je crois que c'est souvent par
manque d'humilité qu'il pêche donc
aujourd'hui il faut essayer de remailler
il faut
il faut avancer de toute façon il faut
remailler par remanier peut-être faut-il
remanier ça ne m'appartient pas mais
remailler reprendre le dialogue
probablement
sans jeter non plus de l'huile sur le
feu même venant de Chine
voilà apparemment ça s'était pas si mal
passé que ça avec Elisabeth borne quand
bien même on arrivait à un désaccord
mais on reprenait une discussion et donc
on pouvait se dire qu'avec le temps la
discussion allait reprendre les
syndicats disent on veut pas on on parle
de rien tant que cette réforme est
encore sur la table oui mais je pense
que tout le monde attend aussi le retour
du Conseil constitutionnel et que les
vrais positions se prendront à ce
moment-là donc alors précisément le
Conseil constitutionnel qui rendra une
double décision vendredi prochain
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez à moi je
suis sereine j'attends et je vais bien
de toute façon soit cette réforme et
bien légale et il faut avancer de toute
en réalité c'est vrai que tout le monde
se braque sur l'âge de 64 ans mais
objectivement la moyenne des personnes
aujourd'hui partent à 63 ans et quelques
mois donc on n'est pas si loin du 64 ans
évoqué c'est une réforme en fait c'est
la réforme Touraine qui est un peu
accélérée donc on voit bien que si on
hystérisait pas le débat comme c'est en
train de se faire aujourd'hui de la part
de qui
aujourd'hui je pense que effectivement
la France insoumise est un petit peu
plus dans la victime malheureusement
d'ailleurs parce que je pense qu'ils
sont en train de perdre des points
d'ailleurs on le voit sur les sondages
c'est aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen qui tire
les marrons du feu alors que la gauche
espérait pouvoir reprendre un peu de
vigueur grâce à cette lutte donc on voit
bien que ça ne les sert pas donc
l'apaisement est nécessaire je pense
aussi que si la candidate et les filles
a perdu en Ariège c'est aussi sur fond
de de
chahut des violences ont eu lieu encore
en marge des cortèges la rotonde le
restaurant La Rotonde à Paris a été pris
possibles c'est le restaurant où
Emmanuel Macron avait fêté sa victoire
du premier tour en 2017 pourquoi il
focalise la colère sur lui aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron selon vous
objectifment quand il se permet de
répondre à Laurent Berger alors qu'il
est en Chine je pense que il a souvent
quelques actes maladroits qui ne font
qu'attiser la colère plutôt que de la
calmer et c'est dommage quel geste vous
attendez lui aujourd'hui ce serait plus
de c'est un geste d'apaisement
que que ce genre de réaction et
qu'est-ce qui pourrait constituer un
geste d'apaisement selon vous parce que
c'est ça aujourd'hui la vraie question
comment on sort de cette crise
je ne saurais pas vous dire comment on
sort de cette crise je pense que
Elisabeth borne commençait à réouvrir le
dialogue je pense que ça pouvait se
faire avec le temps avec le résultat du
Conseil constitutionnel donc attendons
au Conseil constitutionnel il y a la
possibilité selon vous parlementaire de
passer à autre chose de tourner cette
page des retraites
oui évidemment oui pour autant ça veut
pas dire que ça va calmer la colère et
pourtant ça veut pas dire qu'il y aura
pas encore de la violence puisque on
sent bien là je pense qu'il faut
d'ailleurs dissocier il y avait la lutte
pour la retraite
mais où tout le monde
comprend bien que même si ça nous fait
pas plaisir et ça fait plaisir à
personne de se dire qu'on va travailler
plus longtemps c'est clair on se dit que
ça peut malgré tout être nécessaire pour
qu'on ait encore une retraite et puis la
colère globale où on a l'impression où
certains peuvent avoir l'impression
d'être méprisées ou l'inflation arrive
et la vie est quand même compliquée donc
et où certains ont intérêt clairement à
agiter la rue et là pour le coup aussi
bien ceux qui sont calmes que ceux qui
ne le sont pas puisque de toute façon ça
n'est jamais les parties traditionnelles
de gouvernement qui gagnent quand il y a
de l'agitation 111 interpellations hier
154 membres des forces de blessé elle
profite elle profite avec qui la casse
et la violence en général
quoi qu'il arrive soit les extrêmes
parce que certains veulent qu'on ramène
le calme et que pensent-ils il n'y a que
par l'extrême droite qu'on pourra la
ramener soit par l'extrême gauche qui
espère un vrai chaos pour pouvoir
éventuellement amener une révolution en
toute état de cause ça ne sert pas la
majorité des français on va parler de la
mission parlementaire que vous avez mené
pendant plusieurs mois sur les violences
intrafamiliales en accueille Cécile
Siksou qui vous a suivi sur le terrain
[Musique]
vous connaissez Cécile bien sûr elle
vous a suivi pendant plusieurs mois
bonjour Cécile comment ça va vous avez
donc suivi Dominique Verrien dans cette
mission parlementaire qui était consacré
précisément à l'action comment améliorer
finalement cette question la grande
question de votre mission c'est comment
améliorer l'action judiciaire en termes
de violence intrafamiliale Cécile
pourquoi aujourd'hui il y a un besoin de
réformer la justice sur ces questions
alors en matière de violence conjugale
et intrafamiliale la justice elle fait
face à deux problèmes alors le premier
c'est qu'elle est aujourd'hui engorger
par ses affaires avec la libération de
la parole en fait les victimes de
violences conjugales déposent plaintes
beaucoup plus facilement qu'avant et en
5 ans le nombre de plaintes a plus que
doublé en France elles sont passées de
85 000 en 2017 à 208 000 en 2022 donc de
plus en plus de femmes saisissent la
justice et mécaniquement les contentieux
liées à ces questions augmentent et la
conséquence Steve c'est que c'est devenu
du coup de contentieux pour ces
tribunaux c'est le principal contentieux
en fait pour beaucoup de tribunaux le
second problème c'est que la justice
elle est pas prête en fait à accueillir
ces victimes car les personnels en fait
ils sont pas forcément formés pour
répondre à ces contentieux donc quand
une femme va déposer plainte ce qu'elle
attend donc déjà c'est une démarche
compliquée pour elle et ce qu'elle
attend c'est d'être reconnu comme
victime qu'on la protège qu'on prenne en
compte ce qu'elle a vécu et souvent les
plaintes sont classées sans suite elles
sont pas elles se sentent pas crues et
elles sont envoyées chez elles avec leur
conjoint violents donc il y a un
problème la conséquence ça on le sait ça
peut mener à des drames des féminicides
sur en 2022 sur les 147 féminicides il y
avait une vingtaine de femmes qui
avaient porté plainte et justement vous
avez suivi dans votre documentaire une
victime qui a déposé plein de
précisément oui on a suivi Caroline donc
elle a vécu 15 ans avec un compagnon
violent et elle a déposé plainte pour la
première fois au bout de 10 ans après
avoir vécu sous les coups et donc elle
nous raconte comment ça s'est passé
suite à cette plainte je vous propose de
l'écouter
on a été reçus par la substitut du
procureur à l'époque tous les deux
et là je peux vous dire que c'est un
moment terrible
en fait la substitut de la sermonnée
comme un enfant
vous rendez compte monsieur ce que vous
avez fait ça ne se fait pas etc je vous
prie de bien vouloir présenter vos
excuses à Madame et ne plus jamais
recommencer
donc devant la substitut du procureur il
m'a présenté ses excuses et là je me
suis dit mais que se passe-t-il quoi on
n'est pas des enfants et en fait ça
s'est terminé comme ça
vous avez entendu ce témoignage la
réponse de la substitut du procureur
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ou
qu'est-ce que ça révèle alors j'en pense
que la réponse est évidemment totalement
inadaptée d'ailleurs le fait de les
recevoir tous les deux ensemble de les
cérémoner comme si effectivement vous
avez fait une grosse bêtise et c'est un
manque de formation très clair alors
l'histoire est un peu ancienne elle
était connaîte en plus donc je la
connais mais
aujourd'hui réellement on a besoin de
formation pour comprendre quel est ce
système et puis pour pouvoir prendre en
charge très correctement les victimes
mais aussi les auteurs parce que
cet homme si on le prend pas en charge
demain il va recommencer quand bien même
Caroline va le quitter il va recommencer
parce que c'est un système dans lequel
on entre ce système de violence ce
système de contrôle et donc il est
important de prendre en charge mais pour
ça il est important de reconnaître aussi
ce que c'est que la violence ça pas un
conflit on n'est pas à égalité comme
dans la plupart des divorces où on
s'entend pas on sait pas et puis
éventuellement on se dispute mais ça va
pas au-delà réellement la violence
s'accompagne de tout un tas de travers
j'allais dire qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
le contrôle coercitif mais c'est en fait
émaillé de plein de choses on contrôle
comment vous vous habillez comment vous
sortez qui vous rencontrez est-ce que
vous avez le droit de vous servir de
votre argent et on met comme ça la
victime sous emprise et ce qui fait
qu'elle ne peut pas partir c'est une
espèce de Nas dans laquelle on se trouve
j'ai tendance à comparer ça avec une
avec du mazout vous savez un oiseau qui
est dans le mazout et si on le surpasse
si c'est pas quelqu'un d'extérieur qui
le sort et qui lui nettoie les plumes on
ne peut pas s'en sortir seul donc il
faut vraiment aider et pour ça il faut
qu'on ait des services sociaux il faut
qu'on ait de la police de la gendarmerie
et des magistrats formés qui connaissent
ça et qui sachent accompagner d'accord
pour revenir donc 4 Caroline son mari il
a jamais été jugé pour les violences
mais elle a réussi à s'en sortir toute
seule on va dire mais elle a quitté
c'est ça elle l'a quitté et mais après
par la suite elle a quand même eu un
autre parcours judiciaire pour la
séparation et pour la garde des enfants
donc son cas ça montre un petit peu la
complexité en fait de ces quatre
violences conjugales où il faut à la
fois donc punir l'homme violent protéger
la victime gérer la séparation et aussi
protéger les enfants et gérer la garde
des enfants donc potentiellement ces
quatre voire cinq juges différents qui
peuvent travailler sur un même cas d'où
l'idée de mettre en place une
juridiction spécialisée
c'est là-dessus qui a travaillé la
mission parlementaire oui et pour savoir
comment faire la mission parlementaire
elle est allée voir ce qui se passait
chez nos voisins espagnols là-bas c'est
un féminicide en fait qui a fait bouger
les choses c'est le cas Dana au ranch
c'est une femme qui a été tuée par son
mari alors qu'elle avait déposé 15
plaintes son histoire ça a bouleversé la
société en espagnol et suite à cette
affaire en fait ils ont décidé de créer
des juridictions spécialisées qui ont vu
le jour en 2004 et aujourd'hui il y en a
106 en fait sur le territoire espagnol
et on s'est rendu avec donc la mission
parlementaire dans l'un de à Madrid
voilà et comment ça marche donc tous les
juges du tribunal à Madrid la ne font
que ça donc ils ne traite que des cas de
violences conjugales alors c'est un
tribunal violence qui est consacré aux
violences de genre donc il ne juge que
des hommes pas des femmes ils sont
formés à ce contentieux mais surtout
dans le tribunal nous sommes allés tout
est mis en place pour protéger la
victime donc il y a une unité médicale
qui constate les blessures il y a des
policiers sur place en fait pour prendre
les plaintes
il y a un lieu pour les héberger et
surtout il y a une justice rapide en
moins de 72 heures il y a un juge qui
peut prendre des décisions provisoires
pour mettre en sécurité la victime et je
vous propose d'écouter un de ces juges
si elle se sent menacée ou en danger
elle demande au juge une ordonnance de
protection
la décision prise par le juge peut
consister en une injonction
d'éloignement afin que l'accusé ne
puisse ni s'approcher ni entrer en
communication avec elle
et surtout cela permet de résoudre de
façon immédiate et temporaire la
question de savoir qui reste au domicile
familiale qui a la garde des enfants et
le montant de la pension à verser
alors vous vous étiez en Espagne donc
avec
un Espagne est-ce que on peut appliquer
ce système espagnol en France selon eux
alors déjà au niveau espagnol on a
l'impression en tout cas quand on lisait
une proposition de loi qui a été déposée
à l'Assemblée nationale on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait un seul juge
qui allait tout traité un peu comme le
juge des enfants chez nous ça n'est pas
le cas on a là celui qu'on vient de voir
qui est juste aux affaires familiales et
on a bien un juge pénal derrière le juge
pénal derrière il juge trois ans après
aussi donc on n'a pas gagné de temps du
tout sur la partie pénale il faut le
dire par contre là où c'était très
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement au
niveau du juge aux affaires familiales
ça allait très vite c'est ce que vous
disiez on peut tout de suite protéger la
femme et ça nous souhaitons nous en
inspirer après le système judiciaire est
quand même différent et donc nous nous
souhaitions en plus avoir quelque chose
qui soit applicable immédiatement
puisque il est plus temps d'attendre de
savoir ce qu'il faut faire pour pouvoir
protéger les femmes donc il faut le
faire tout de suite et nous avons fait
le choix de nous appuyer sur le système
système existant mais effectivement en
créant des chambres spécialisées du coup
on n'a pas un juge qui fait tout comme
le juge des enfants on a plusieurs juges
mais qui sont au sein d'une même chambre
l'avantage c'est quoi c'est un pour
rentrer dans cette chambre il faut avoir
cette formation dont on vient de parler
une formation plus plus sur ce que c'est
que le phénomène du psycho-traumatique
du contrôle coercitif etc une fois qu'on
a cette formation plus plus il faut
aussi travailler ensemble et donc avoir
un partage d'informations entre le juge
l'affaire familiale le juge des enfants
le juge pénal et éventuellement le juge
des libertés et de la détention et tous
les juges qui peuvent être amenés à
juger dans le système français avec un
assistant de justice à on a vu que ça
pouvait se faire ça se fait déjà à
Châlons-en-Champagne ça se fait déjà à
Clermont-Ferrand et donc à partir de là
il y a un vrai partage d'informations et
on traite et ça c'est aussi une chose
qu'on demande c'est que ce soit la
situation familiale qui soit traitée et
non pas seulement le cas de l'homme le
cas de la femme au juge et affaires
familiales et le cas de l'enfant au juge
des enfants on veut que ce soit la
situation familiale qui soit traitée on
obtiendra pas forcément une unité de
temps encore que chez nous le pénal peut
aller beaucoup plus vite que que le
civil on n'aura pas forcément une unité
de temps par contre on aura une unité de
décision en tout cas aux personnes
ignorera la décision de l'autre quand il
aura à apprendre la sienne jamais le
juge aux affaires familiales ne dira je
veux pas que l'homme rencontre la femme
pendant que le juge des enfants dit il
faut que l'homme vienne chercher les
enfants chez la femme toutes les
semaines vous parlez au futur vous avez
remis votre rapport à les absorbes
qu'est-ce qu'elle en a fait qu'est-ce
qu'elle va en faire
les coordonnées mais bien évidemment ce
sera chez Isabelle
Rome les
axes passés
és du règlementaire qui pourra
s'appliquer tout de suite et du
législatif qui devra passer par une loi
Éric Dupond-Moretti nous a assuré qui
est des réceptions de notre rapport et
donc ça c'était la semaine dernière il
allait faire analyser les choses pour
voir ce qui relevait du réglementaire ce
qui relevait du législatif pour vraiment
tout
l'appliquer peut-être que d'ailleurs le
législatif pourrait passer dans le
projet de loi de programmation de la
justice je ne le sais pas en tout cas
c'est une réflexion
de la République qui a dit une loi avant
l'été donc ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire avant l'été donc voilà et puis
surtout c'est bientôt et vraiment une
assurance d'Éric Dupont-Moretti qu'il
allait prendre en compte toutes nos
préconisations pour pouvoir les
appliquer et d'ailleurs notre rapport
c'est à l'aune de cette réflexion que
nous l'avons aussi fait pour que tout
soit applicable est-ce qu'on a les
moyens aujourd'hui de d'appliquer ces
recommandations alors on a aujourd'hui
mais Cécile le disait aujourd'hui c'est
déjà 30 à 40% des cas donc de toute
façon aujourd'hui c'est traité parfois
maltraité mais c'est traité donc ce ces
affaires là sont pas des affaires
nouvelles qui font arriver pour autant
si on veut les traiter mieux
effectivement il nous faudra des moyens
il faut des moyens alors surtout non moi
je dirais plus de forces vives donc plus
de magistrats plus de greffiers plus
assistante justice mais j'ai bien
entendu aussi que oui bien sûr mais ça
dépend comment on transforme l'argent et
moi j'aime bien quand le l'argent se
transforme en humain en l'occurrence
parce que là c'est vraiment d'humain
dont on a besoin et j'ai bien entendu
aussi que le ministre de la Justice
avait promis 1500 magistrats 1500 gifiés
et 10000 assistants de justice
supplémentaires dans les 5 ans qui
viennent et nous nous disons minimum 30%
sur cette politique de toute façon c'est
30% des délits il y a aucune raison
qu'on n'est pas au moins 30% de ses
forces supplémentaires qui viennent sur
cette politique publique et et après
nous demandons effectivement un vrai
pilotage de la politique et un fond
dédié comme ça on saura à combien on met
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu
réparti partout un peu un peu chez les
victimes un peu dans le droit des femmes
c'est c'est un peu dans l'un des
délinquance et l'idée c'est d'avoir un
fond dédié et là on sera réellement et
on pourra mieux aider les associations
qui travaillent là-dessus vous avez eu
un retour du ministre justement sur
cette demande de fond alors objet
techniquement c'est pour ça que j'en
parle parce que c'est un appel le fond
et le pilotage c'est vraiment une chose
que l'on attend je pense qu'ils avaient
ROM est tout à fait d'accord maintenant
c'est pas à elle qui va le décider là je
crois d'ailleurs que ce sera plutôt chez
la première ministre que ça va se
décider mais nous allons aussi a priori
probablement bientôt la rencontrer donc
nous pouvons pour vous vice-présidente à
la délégation au bord des femmes vous
avez acheté Playboy cette semaine je ne
l'ai pas acheté
je suis pas vraiment abonnée
j'imagine que vous avez vu les photos
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire alors ce
genre d'affichage ça m'inspire une
question mais quel est ce monde où pour
exister quand on est une femme politique
on a besoin de poser dans Playboy et
plus loin pour poser dans Playboy on a
besoin avant d'être allé faire du buzz
chez Hanouna et que sinon on existe pas
si on vous parle d'Isabelle Rome on ne
sait pas qui c'est et pourtant si on
s'intéresse au fond parce que la seule
chose au niveau du droit des femmes
qu'on pourrait attribuer à Marlène
Schiappa c'est le Grenelle des violences
conjugales or qui piloter le Grenelle
des violences conjugales et qui a
travaillé sur le fond sur les grenades
de violences conjugales c'est Isabelle
Rome notre ministre actuel mais la
personne n'en parle et donc pour pouvoir
en parler il faut faire du buzz
aujourd'hui ça fait pas avancer la cause
de l'égalité homme-femme ce que font les
médias aujourd'hui qui ne mettent en
avant que des femmes qui vont poser dans
Playboy ça ne fait pas avancer la cause
vous nous parlez du du fond en parlant
de ce rapport donc la presse écrite
parle du fond en parlant de ce rapport
mais les qui sont réellement très
écoutés etc est-ce que ils ont proposé
Amélie Chandler ou à moi-même devenir
présenter le rapport est-ce qu'ils ont
parlé à Isabelle Rome de ce rapport
personne par contre on va parler de
Playboy et on va parler de Marlène
Schiappa qui restera du coup dans le
gouvernement parce que elle fait du buzz
et peut-être pas Isabelle Roms qui
serait dommage parce qu'elle fait du
travail je vous confirme qu'on fait pas
ce genre de une ici beaucoup Cécile pour
votre chronique on va regarder ce qui se
passe au plus près du terrain grâce à
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
aujourd'hui direction Roanne dans la loi
on va retrouver Pierre Olivier Véro vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de l'île
d'omadaire le pays bonjour
Pierre-Olivier vous revenez dans vos
pages sur les conséquences de l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi risque qui porte
notamment sur l'intérim médical
oui bonjour donc cette semaine
effectivement nous nous sommes
intéressés à la situation très
problématique de du Centre Hospitalier
du foret donc entre Saint-Étienne et
Erwan qui regroupe deux sites Feurs et
Montbrison alors bien sûr ce sont des
petites villes mais le bassin de santé
est très étendu les infrastructures
routières pas forcément
excellente et suite à la mise en
application de la loi risque aux 3 avril
au 3 oui
qui plafonne donc les revenus des
médecins intérimaires autour de 1300
euros la journée
cet hôpital a constaté une certaine
désertion des médecins intérimaires la
direction estime à environ à 30%
maintenant le la proportion de médecins
manquants et face à cette pénurie et
bien la direction a décidé tout
simplement de regrouper les urgences sur
un un des deux sites à Montbrison
privant le deuxième site celui de Feurs
de service des urgences alors évidemment
un médecin restant et la population font
remarquer que des habitants se trouvent
maintenant à 40 minutes du site le plus
proche disposant d'un service d'urgence
alors évidemment déjà en situation
courante ça pose ça pose un certain
problème de sécurité sanitaire et on
ose imaginer une situation une crise
sanitaire type covid si on devait faire
face voilà une telle situation
alors bien sûr on sait que cette
cette problématique est pas limitée au
département de la Loire que
beaucoup d'établissements sont concernés
sur le territoire national notamment
secteur rural et on craint que ce ne
fasse que accentuer encore la fracture
sanitaire
c'est justement est-ce que on peut
envisager ce qui vous semble souhaitable
possible la journée cette ou de modifier
cette loi comme le demande certains
établissements et quoi qu'il en soit
comment concilier la santé financière
des établissements et leurs bon
fonctionnement
alors moi j'étais plutôt favorable à
cette loi d'ailleurs parce que en
réalité le principe c'est de limiter le
montant donné parce que réellement
parfois dans certains établissements on
était payés très très cher une nuit pour
dormir parce qu'on n'avait pas forcément
une urgence et c'était parfaitement
injuste par rapport au médecin qui sont
en place donc je pense que c'est
nécessaire par contre c'est pour ça
qu'il fallait une loi et que ça
s'applique au niveau national et donc il
faut que tout le monde la respecte à
partir du moment où il y a un montant
maximum de toute façon les médecins qui
faisaient cet intérim et qui travaillent
très clairement ils vont continuer à
travailler ils seront payés moins
probablement peut-être que du coup ça
leur fera choisir des postes fixes dans
les hôpitaux donc moi je suis pas
forcément pour revenir en arrière je
suis par contre pour qu'elle s'applique
or j'ai cru entendre que déjà certains
hôpitaux commençaient à désobéir et à
remettre
une surenchère
luttons contre tous ceux qui mettent une
surenchère faisons qu'il y ait un vrai
tarif
appliquons ce tarif et après on verra si
ça n'a pas un peu mieux régulé mais je
vois pas pourquoi ça ne se régulerait
pas quand même on peut pas continuer à
avoir cette concurrence et à celui qui
peut en mettre le plus aura du coup des
médecins et celui qui peut pas et ben du
coup les gens pourront mourir tranquille
merci beaucoup Pierre-Olivier je vais
rappeler la une de vos deux éditions du
jour vous dit 100 ans de vélo et
porte-claude aux urgences de Feurs merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de rien d'avoir ici avec
nous ce matin dans 20 minutes on
reviendra sur la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites ce sera dans le
club jusqu'où ira à l'épreuve de force
avec le gouvernement on posera la
question à nos clubs vous avez vu le
film les petites victoires de musique
Verrien non malheureusement pourtant moi
Saint-Sauveur en Puisaye fait partie des
petites victoires je crois et ben
précisément vous allez laisser votre
place à nos invités du jour c'est
l'équipe du film Les petites victoires
qui nous rejoignent tout de suite